sono riuscito a trovare online il gioco
di dora l'esploratrice bè penso che la
conoscete tutti se non la conoscete
se non conoscete forse è meglio dare
alle sue strisce questa bambina che
trova le cose che nessuno proverebbe mai
in onore di dora hanno fatto un gioco
chiamato d'ora è morta d'ora è morta
quindi niente giochiamolo perché un
horror
a quanto pare hanno fatto un horror su
dora l'esploratrice chi sono io per non
metterci mano andiamo subito io non so
cosa ne sto facendo della mia vita ma va
bene così quindi ragazzi siamo sud ora
is the dream e hanno fatto un rimaste
red cioè perché c'era una versione
l'hanno fatta hanno ri masterizzata
fantastica diciamo start vediamo cosa
succede io non so non ho mai visto dora
l'esploratrice fortunatamente nella mia
vita
infatti sono cresciuto secondo me
abbastanza male allora vediamo di
capirci per bene come si fanno ste robe
la di qua vado ci hanno fatto le master
ed ci vuole che si è giocata
all'ambiente giocato che hanno fatto la
versione quella fatta meglio
wow queste robe mi riempie di gioia
seguo le frecce dove ed ora dov'è quel
demonio in persona ma scusami come ho
fatto renderlo horror
c'è un ad ora versione spaventoso perché
tutto sbarrato porte chiuse quindi nei
modi fuori c'è la versione remasse radif
anche abbastanza schifo come era la
versione normale scusatemi un cancello
sembra la mia via d'uscita si vede
proprio che gioco di dora questo caso
dice cosa ovvia maledizione chiuso
bisogno di trovare una chiave proprio
macchiare gigante a quanto vedo bene non
trovare una chiave posso andare in giro
tra le chiavi che fuori c'è una chiave
signorina ad ora ha mica per caso
signori signorina ad ora dov'è cos'è
cos'è sta roba dio mio
o noi quella d'ora sembra d'ora senza un
occhio e senza la parte di sotto del
corpo
è orribile va bene signorina ad ora sun
per caso dove si trova le chiese
registrano le chiavi che io no
disperatamente bisogno ecco la cosa
bella visto gioco che non finisce la la
stamina quando corri almeno quello
solo che si trovi un vicolo cieco è un
problema da una cosa no a montalcino è
fortissima quando devo andare aiuto
aiuto aiuto
calmati fermati trova i tuoi
orsacchiotti del cuore fa qualcosa
dovendo seguire la freccia scommetto poi
dico forse sto tornando all'inizio non è
proprio il massimo perché noi degli
importi ragazzi non solo che sto andando
bisogni trovano a chiave l'avete ma
rimasterizzata la chiave almeno quella
perché se non un problema
madonna ma un ascolto di dosso non
impossibile signora io il 5 milioni di
iscritti sei anni di youtube gli o
ridotti a questo a panico si esce pure
ci sono un sacco riusciti il suo posto
non ancora ci sono delle aree
sbloccabili ha smesso di seguirmi il che
non è non è male perfetto forse dovrei
smetterla di parlare ragazzi troviamo la
chiave ed ora deve farsi un paio di
mazzi suoi per ragazzi un labirinto
orribile mai giocata la roma così apriti
premi e propria bhatti premuto e proprio
portobello permesso
ma non c'è riflessione gli specchi
cavolo non l'avrei mai detto
un gioco così ben fotografano la vera
riflessione gli specchi lato la sento
sussurrare speriamo in un intrigo dentro
hermione no no vai a casa tua per cavani
la porta non si chiudono le porte non
hanno fatto la funzione chiudiporta
maglia datemi la chiave vi prego trova
un martello per rimuovere le ma come non
trova hanno fatto chiave dentro chi
inside credo che la chiave sia lì dentro
visto scritto chiave dentro
va bene allora ritrovare una roba
decente martello se non posso abc anche
lei io ho visto delle robe che si
muovevano qua dentro cosa si trova una
pagina this lander man
non so se è sangue o cos'è sta roba qua
sai che non ho capito niente di quello
che c'è scritto aspetta che traduco c'è
scritto secondo google traduttore vado a
strappo il tuo budella out e divorare m
come un savage signorina ad ora mi deve
divorare come un sap ag
no perché io non sono un savage pure
cioè manco pagata correnti già non ci
sono e chiavi e meno una corrente
cavalca morto tra un martello un
martello per cortesia un martello avete
masterizzato anche il martello per
favore
quanto tempo per un martello ha così poi
[Musica]
la mia vita ha assunto le tue gambe sono
mie ma cosa te ne fai le mie gambe ma
perché sono sexy ma vabbè fino a un
certo punto non me l'aspettavo mai bene
non aprea non aprite quella porta
signori ai nomi non mi ricordavo pur
caccia vacca se difficile va beh posso
andare devo andare questo al cancello o
no devo andare forza e dove gli altri
trovata way out trova la chiave del
cancello che la spunta ad ora per favore
trovasto martello già difficile che dove
perché sono entrato in una porta
randomica dead and no no no no ce l'ha
fatta
ci credo che culo
nel momento in cui non devo trovare una
via d'uscita un posto senza via d'uscita
l'ho trovato perfetto nella solito
brucio de anima o eccolo totò martello
c'è una roba che va a fuoco cipur ed ora
lì c'è un autobus fatto veramente male
sembra una faccina che sputa del cile
devo fare devo fare il dribbling ad ora
ok perfetto ce l'ho fatta il miracolo
incredibile vai vai vai veloce e ho
trovato il martello quindi apro quella
porta lì una volta che l'ho aperta trova
la chiave scritto chi inside speriamo li
si perché non ho molta autonomia io di
corsa punto bar perché bella che mamma
mia e me lo sogno lo stanno te lo dico
chi inside apri apri apri apri bene
chiave veloce però fatto tempo adulti
non dirò che l'ho presa presa veloce è
stato semplice e ci da qua sì magari
sottoservizi tua sorella è semplice
madonna rega che anzi rivivere dove era
riuscita non mi ricordo più
quanto è veloce quella non c'è ma anche
ai gambe ce l'ho fatta ma che ce l'ho
fatto ho vinto è stato è stato orribile
ho vinto giuro come la chiave non entra
come non è tra la chiave no non ci crede
quindi no amici devo trovare la vera
chiave ma come la vera chiave ma sei
scemo ma la chiave
no ragazzi aspettano non è vero tra
tutti i posti non è possibile che forse
quel posto di fuori che ci ha scritto
non adesso ma dai non troverò mai più
come ho fatto a trovarlo prima come ho
fatto a trovare un gioco del genere lo
so solo io piu rimpiante ci sono solo i
miei capelli guarda vabbè ed ora senti
dammi un attimo di tregua perché non mi
ricordo dove il posto di prima
qua i miei savage quindi niente
che palle dai veramente regala zero ogni
volta da zero che rottura come ora che
non c'è più il martello cosa si è perso
il martello mera qua ma come non era lì
il martello che aveva la posizione del
martello quindi il martello e randomico
siete pazzi
cos'è qua
la smettiamo porcaccia vabbè vabbè è
caduto non sono stato io ve lo giuro
dov'è il martello vi prego cos'è sta
roba
quindi via via via via via via sta
succendo che sono in un posto che non ho
mai visto prima
cos'è odio la mia vita ma come faccio a
essere qui di nuovo aiuto madonna che
anzi la mia vita
raga non troppo il mart e ve lo giuro ed
è sposato il martello non c'è più cioè
se l'avessi e se ci fosse ancora
ritrovato impossibile
e stranissimo che non ci sia ve lo giuro
il cav h schifosa dai basta basta basta
mi sono rotto basta orribile raga il
battello è scomparso non c'era più
seconda un bug perché avevo impossibile
io non so cosa ho appena giocato non so
descrivere
vabbè questo era d'ora è morta ma vi
giuro di non so come mai sport è sparito
il martello peccato avrei voluto finire
questo capolavoro videoludico moderno
peccato che non possa venire mi dispiace
proprio non so se si vede ma mi dispiace
come sei ragazzi spero che mi è piaciuto
noi ci vediamo come sempre hanno
conseguito dai ragazzi
[Musica]